we're here to stand with the people of
turkey and Syria in the wake of this
devastating earthquake I just had a
chance to fly over uh say to see some of
the devastation and
it's really hard to put them into words
you see
building still standing and then
buildings collapse Roots destroyed
and right next right next to it
something that's still still standing
um but it gives you some sense of the
scale of this we've had tens of
thousands of deaths
tens of millions of people affected by
this earthquake and of course we still
don't know the full extent of it we've
uh had about uh 85 billion dollars worth
of assistance poured in immediately for
housing water and food and medicine and
clothing all that in the immediate days
following the earthquake today I can
announce that we will be putting in
another 100 million dollars
to assist those who are so desperately
in need this is going to be a long-term
effort the search and rescue
unfortunately is coming to an end the
recovery
operation is on and then there'll be a
massive new building effort when you see
the extent of the damage the number of
buildings the number of Apartments the
number of homes that have been destroyed
it's going to take a massive effort to
rebuild but we're committed to
supporting securing that effort with
many countries around the world are
doing the same there's tremendous
solidarity and tremendous determination
to see this through the most important
thing right now is to get assistance to
people who need it to get them through
the winter and to get them back on their
time but simply put the United States is
Here We Stand strongly with the people
of trickier and the people of Syria
through our NGO implementing partners
and we'll stick with it until we all get
the job done it's it's a very
challenging situation
having said that we're trying to
maximize the assistance that we and
others can provide the
[Music]
destruction the Damage Done in Syria is
is very very significant and it too
needs a massive assistance effort we'll
do everything we can including making
sure for example that there is
absolutely no doubt that whatever
sanctions exist on Syria do not affect
the provision of humanitarian systems